this morning in the dish a visit to
perhaps the most famous farm-to-table
restaurant in the country a place that's
been affected like so many others by the
pandemic but also a place that's trying
to improve the way we farm cook and eat
in the future 30 miles north of New York
City at Blue Hill at Stone Barns the
fields are healthy and full inside so is
the dining room but not with customers
it's the staff typically waiting tables
now filling boxes it's a little bit like
you and I standing on the shoreline
watching a tsunami come in I mean this
is the greatest generational collapse of
the kind of farming that we want to
support and we're facing it when the
pandemic shut down Dan barbers world
renowned restaurants it didn't just
leave diners seeking a high-end
experience out of a reservation it
threatened to ruin the entire farming
system Blue Hill has built up we started
to realize when we talk to these farmers
about what happens of restaurant reopens
but does 50% of the business or 50% of
sales to the to the farm for the farmer
and what if farmers markets because of
social distancing are down 50% all of a
sudden you start to look at a landscape
that's very different from what farms
have really ever experienced in this
generation and what they have started
telling us was like well that's
bankruptcy that we cannot do that left
with bountiful halls from local harvests
but no one able to eat inside barber
turned his operation into a food
processing center all of it carefully
prepped and placed not on plates but in
a box the box has changed pretty much
everyday there's themes you know we have
the fish box theme we have the the pork
box we have the the beef box and we have
something called a car wash a box which
is really a grab bag from all over the
kitchen the Box program is called
resourced capital IDI at the end for
education bill is a way to support the
independent local food movement during
the crisis but a program like this is
never going to make the same money or
support the same level of employment as
charging hundreds of dollars for a
multi-course meal
so it's Stone Barns barber and his
farming guru of 20 years Jack algier are
also trying to position the dining world
post pandemic this is all about
succession yeah that's right well this
what you're in right here is we call our
lettuce block multiple successions or
different timing and plantings of
lettuce greens celtuce escarole
thousands ten thousands of heads here in
this is only a fifth of an acre in this
block I try some of us sure yeah try a
lower leaf there just you stack it off
snap it sideways this was called celtuce
now we also call it asparagus lettuce
what we grow here is really a broad
diversity of crops in relationship with
our community you know harvests pretty
regularly year-round not like one big
bulb called foot it's not easy it's not
easy but I guess it's it's whole for
those without the kind of land Blue Hill
has Algerian barber are pushing a 12 by
15 foot garden concept and then you go
back to about 45 degrees maybe bend your
legs a tiny bit but don't bend over it's
a way for homeowners and unemployed
cooks to learn and adapt and the cooks
started planting they're sort of dream
garden three very distinctive cooks with
three very distinctive gardens that got
them digging into the dirt they started
sending by Instagram and slack and
whatever these guys these Millennials do
that's it's all they and also have a
look up and they're out-of-work cooks in
Texas in Michigan in Colorado that are
following these guys recipes and so
we're like man there's something going
on here that's like Electrify I mean
really guys these kids were so excited
the 12 by 15 foot garden playbook that
algier design was put on display for us
by Pruitt Kuragin you trained at CIA
this yeah this is a whole different
training whole different thing born in
Thailand her job is as a line cook or
was for me before this like cooking for
people was the way that I connected with
them the way that I communicate with
them and with that gone it was like how
am I gonna
interact with people you know at a time
when like everything seems very much
like it's changing day today gardening
means that you actually have to plan for
the future and it's it's kind of nice to
be able to think about a future this
small garden done right should be able
to produce a thousand pounds of food a
season including here wasabi
arugula this is wasabi arugula oh wow oh
my goodness yeah it's so good that's
incredible but here's the catch how do
they make money though
with this well it's not a money-making
adventure this is you know most of them
are unemployment and most of them are
have a lot of time on their hands and so
this is an opportunity for them to be
educated it's like a graduate school
that's what it is so that they can be
even better when they can eventually
come back that's exactly right and what
about when they have their own
restaurants take that further I mean
this is like a compass for how they
wanted to find the restaurant in the
future barber does not know when his
restaurant here will reopen or what it
looks like when it does but for him a
short-term crisis should not change the
long-term goal cultivate cook and
consume quality once you have this kind
of food and once you experience what a
farmer experiences every day your frame
for buying food into your restaurant
changes for chefs the road is clear and
I hope that we become spokespersons for
that kind of future because it's the
delicious one I'm planting my wasabi
arugula garden as we speak Michelle and
for emotional health it's a wonderful
thing thank you so much chef